[Music]  hell hath no fury like a Targaryen  scorned on Sundays Game of Thrones we  witnessed one of the most intense battle  scenes in the show's history the  Lannister army versus Daenerys Targaryen  and the Dothraki  plus the O so terrifying drogon drogon  was vicious and relentless Lannisters  were wiped out left and right but just  when they thought all hope was lost  bran launches an arrow that leaves  drogon badly wounded with Daenerys on  land tending to dragons injury  Jaime goes in for the kill but it  doesn't exactly go as planned is Jaime  dead will drogon lead Daenerys to the  Iron Throne with just three episodes  left in Game of Thrones seventh season  things sure are Nina  [Music]  you